he's one of my favorite people that have
gotten a chance to meet in this business
I love chatting with him and certainly
these are interesting times for the city
of Las Vegas and the Las Vegas Raiders
and everything about it he is the
managing editor of Eason he is the
legendary Brent Musburger how are you
Brent I'm fine rich under the you know
under the circumstances and I know you
and I and everybody out here show which
is nothing but the best especially for
our medical personnel who are working
around the clock to to treat victims of
this horrible virus and but the one
thing I did notice today mm-hmm and I
know there was controversy about the NFL
going with a date to start the season
and have the talk about free agency I
thought it was a good distraction I
thought it was needed I know that and
I'm speaking personally yep I really
enjoyed going over and of listening to
the shows talk about where will Tom
Brady wind up and you know on and on it
was because you know I think you can
lock yourself up with the tragedies for
just so long we're all addicted to
social media all of us there's no
question about that
and we pick up our phone and immediately
we go to see what the latest bulletins
are and they're depressing and I thought
the NFL offers an escape today and
obviously it's very disappointing to the
city of Las Vegas to lose to lose the
upcoming draft but there will be other
drafts down the road it will come to Las
Vegas but now we can talk about the
draft because the NFL is going to hold
it the last week of April and obviously
as you know they can do that on a
teleconference and and you can wire up
certain places for the NFL Network and
ESPN will do the same so so at least we
have you know because talking about the
NFL offers hope because their season
doesn't start until the first week of
September so I know and I'm speaking I'm
really speaking personally right I
enjoyed I enjoyed the talk very very
much and like everybody else
and yourself included we're all
interested we're Tom Brady is going to
is going to wind up and it you know we
can't do too much we didn't work kind of
a quarantine locked up staying away from
our usual hangouts and it offered me a
good escape well before we can escape
together down some of those questions
about the NFL and about the Tom Brady
watch and whether the Raiders are in on
it I do want to however hit what is
going on in your town there and and what
it looks like and what what the lack of
sports means for the community there
Brent I want to give you the floor and
talk about people who are affected and
and what we should know about in your
estimation well full disclosure now
mmm-hmm I drove out of Las Vegas and I'm
up at our place in Montana okay with
with the family but I have I have spoken
to people who are on the scene Derek
Stevens who owns several casinos
downtown in his building the new one on
Fremont Street circa and is a huge
sports fan he was the first to alert me
to the fact that the strip was virtually
deserted and following that about 24
hours later of course MGM and when both
announced that they were shutting down
their casinos for the time being now
when MGM shuts down rich that involves
20 separate casinos they also own the
Bellagio of the Mirage and you can go on
and on with with the list including
three casinos right there around the
t-mobile Center with the Vegas cool the
Knights were playing and Mandalay Bay
which is right across from Interstate 15
from works stadium is being built now
work continues on Allegiant Stadium and
much construction outside of course
keeps the workers a little bit away from
each other there's not collection of
workers but as they get closer and
closer they're putting on the roof and
it's a permanent roof it's not
retractable when they do that then of
course there will be cluster
workers on the inside now everybody
everybody around the Raiders keeping
their fingers crossed that construction
will not slow down and on August 22nd
which is a Saturday Garth Brooks is due
to have a concert in Allegiant stadium
whether or not there will be a preseason
game or whether or not UNLV is able to
play California which is a game on the
schedule for that none of us really know
the first date that has been scheduled
and again it's for the time being when
everything that's going on is August
22nd then they hope they can get it done
now Darrin Stephens Tomi's at downtown
and of course these are issues which
caused New York Illinois Ohio to close
down their restaurants that are bars
there were large crowds gathering around
the casinos on Fremont Street now of
course in view of the fact that the CDC
wants clusters of 50 people broken up
and basically to stay apart and don't
socialize as much they feel that that's
one of the weapons in in fighting this
horrible virus I would guess that the
crowds down there will start to fade
away obviously it's going to be an
enormous and enormous hit on the city of
Las Vegas and I feel so badly as
everyone else does for the part-time
workers and those who are being it off I
saw that when was trying trying to keep
on as many employees as they could
meanwhile MGM has already started about
layoffs and of course a much bigger with
all the properties that they have the
local casinos such as stations the South
Point with the beats in studio is owned
by Michael gone they are still open
restaurants are still open but the
crowds are way way down and of course
the casinos depend on large crowds
conventions have been canceled
most of them none of the conventioneers
will be coming to Las Vegas and we don't
know when that will get repaired and
restored but it's just it's an exam
of the financial hit that the entire
country is going to take as a result of
this you can you can feel for the
airline industry and their employees or
like a cruise ship industry anybody
involved in travel and leisure
activities is suffering an enormous and
enormous financial hit but in the long
run if what we know is is accurate with
regarding this virus and and we should
stay away from large crowds and we will
come out of it now I think this is
personal opinion mm-hmm I think the
earliest we can count on any kind of
restoration of activities is Memorial
Day I had originally hoped it was going
to be the end of April but I'm seeing
signs that that's not going to be the
case and obviously the industries in Las
Vegas where I live they're dependent on
tourism and tourists conventions coming
in and and the excitement generated by
the new stadium Allegiant stadium with
Las Vegas Raiders will play but there is
hope that we're going to have an entire
NFL season and and what you have going
forward for you you have hope that
there's something down the road and and
you know none of us you don't you don't
give up on something like this you
listen to the good advice that the
experts have you go on about your
business because life eventually has to
go on as far as the sports betting
industry is concerned you know I've
talked about this before yes Brent a
football rains there's no question about
it nothing else is even close to it and
and so obviously this optimism going
through free agency the draft and then
thinking about I think opening day is
that for around September 6th in Kansas
City because I noticed that the Royals
have canceled their game that night have
gone to a doubleheader on Tuesday which
obviously means that MLB and NFL
officials have been talking about when
the opening game is going to be held
Super Bowl champs but that gives us a
little hope to look down the future and
things yes of Las Vegas the situation is
bleak and bleak for peace in
but you know we hope to stay healthy and
the country hopes to come out of this
but we're going it's going to be some
tough times I think we all know that no
doubt Brent Brent Musburger here on the
Rich Eisen show on a well put as always
so let's let's stroll down I guess the
the the fun escapist wormhole for for a
few more minutes here the in your
estimation the starting quarterback for
the Las Vegas Raiders in 2020 would be
who I'll say Derek Carr only because I
like him so much as a young man right
and I and I get I get the chatter I
understand it the Raiders don't have to
sell tickets and so whereas the Chargers
do have to sell tickets you and I both
know in Los Angeles or the second team I
always thought that Tom Brady made more
sense with the Chargers and the Raiders
rich because of that I would not be
surprised if the Raiders don't draft a
quarterback at some point in the
upcoming draft someone to come in
underneath Derek Carr and and work there
and went back and look Richard some of
the teams that had changed city's most
recent I guess will be the Rams well
note the charges that but the Rams going
into st. from st. Louis into Los Angeles
very difficult first year and I think
it's going to be a very difficult year
for the Raiders to you you can just
imagine what this has done to all those
folks that have to move logistically
right they're finishing up new offices
you've got a moving company now you've
been slowed down by this buying of
houses but at any rate I would make
Derek Carr the favorite to to open as
John Burton's quarterback in year three
of his tenure as head coach so do you
think the Raiders are maybe kicking the
tires on Tom communicating with him in
any way shape or form or that's just not
really happening based on your potential
knowledge I would think they would I
would think they would kick the tires
I've very limited knowledge I am aware
of where they're seriously looking at
free agents okay and my list did not
include portney now they might not want
to include me or somebody else in that I
understand that but it appears in the
list I went through which is sort of
interesting because it did include one
offensive player Kenyan Couric who was
franchised today early by Arizona and of
course the reason why is that the
Cardinals traded David Johnson short
time after that and acquired DeAndre
Hopkins from from Houston which I think
is the most surprising yeah it's about
to say what do you think of that trade
Brent what do you think of that one well
I'm a big fan of DeAndre Hopkins okay so
in the short term I give the Cardinals a
big grade on that could be Tyler Murray
now one of the great ball catchers that
I've been around in the league and then
when he played at Clemson also covered
him down there now you have to say hold
on about Houston because they've still
got a couple of draft choices down the
road and let's see what they do with the
the additional second-round David
Johnson to me rich has not played as
well I think you're well aware of this
as I am since the injury and Kenyan
Drake was picked up by the Cardinals
from Miami and was very very good as a
running back and obviously the Raiders
have Jacobs as their star and starter
epic Drake would have given a little bit
of depth back there at position along
with Jalen Rashard as the as a third
down pass blocking specialist so I was
surprised to tell you the truth when
that news broke I think that's the
biggest development of the day and I
think it gives the Cardinals a Stanley
you put you put him with Fitzgerald
who's in probably the final year of a
Hall of Fame career can work underneath
and DeAndre can work a little bit deeper
those are good weapons and of course the
Cardinals are in in my mind the toughest
division of them all and that's the NFC
West right now Brent Musburger a few
minutes left with Brent here on the Rich
Eisen show if there's any city that you
know you know many cities in this great
country very well Chicago's definite
one of them and the report is that teddy
bridgewater might be on the way there
how do you think that that plays out if
Teddy Bridgewater winds up in Chicago
right I'm a huge fan of Teddy
Bridgewater wherever he goes I think
he's going to be a success
Mitchell Comiskey was an overreach when
they traded up to take him down I mean
they took him ahead of you know a couple
of great great prospects as quarterbacks
including Patrick Mahone
so Mitchell you know he just he had not
played enough at North Carolina rich
really not taken enough snaps I was I
was always wondering about that because
I had covered colleges and he wasn't
discussed quarterback when you went
around the country people didn't openly
talk about him I'm sure he's a fine
young man I've you know not trying to
say anything negative about him as an
individual and if you go back to that
one playoff game he brought the Bears
down and then it was a field goal the
double the double Kleinert
that cost him moving on in the playoffs
so but I'm not surprised but to go back
to Bridgewater to be able to come back
from that horrendous injury the ways
handled himself and then I thought one
of the best streaks in the league last
year was when he stepped in for the
injured group Brees and let the Saints
to five consecutive wins I thought that
was one of the great quarterbacking
performances of the season so I wish
Teddy nothing nothing but the best
wherever he goes I think he'll be
successful all right Brent boy I wanted
to reach out because obviously this is
significant for for so many communities
but Las Vegas was first on my mind
knowing that the draft might not happen
and then that that was the case today
with the league saying that they're
gonna run it out of I'm assuming New
York City and it'll still be televised
by my network in ESPN and I thought of
you and I just think of you because
you're you're a treasure man and I hope
you've taken care of yourself and seems
like you're holed up there in Montana
and I'm thrilled to hear that
yeah you know obviously great to be
surrounded by family and everybody up
here in Montana but I wish I wish the
same for you and the entire staff and
and all your great viewers and listeners
and by the one thing I want to have a
little a little lighter note I want to
know when you ran the 40th indeed is
younger were you a tick slower than the
previous year I just I was I was I was
it tick faster however oh good however
however George Kittel came to timing
from the 49ers a wonderful guy don't he
and his wife donate it to st. Jude he
may have given me a gracious flick of
the finger you may or may not have I
don't know but I'm going to take that
five nine seven and literally and
figuratively run with it Brent alright
man best view of the family right back
at you thanks for the call Brent that's
Brent moss well grant the great Brent
Musburger